[Musique]
alors le principe en fait c'est d'être
présent avec deux coachs professionnels
qui sont psychologues pour pouvoir
répondre à toutes les questions et
inquiétudes que peuvent avoir les
parents concernant leur rôle
d'accompagnant on a mis en place en fait
un petit côté zen attitude où les
parents vont pouvoir s'asseoir dans des
fauteuils qui sont confortables tout ça
pour écouter de la musique zen ils ont
également des apprentis esthéticienne
qui seront présentes pour leur faire
tout ce qui est ma sages conseils
maquillage ce genre de choses pour
pouvoir aborder justement toutes ces
problématiques de façon plus détendue
nous
c'est compliqué d'avoir tous les
renseignements malgré les sites internet
et toujours inquiet oui parce que bon
c'est pas facile à chercher ça sans
apprentissage foot rue des employeurs
donc c'est très compliqué
vous